well for tyler glass now you think about
his last start dwayne we knew something
was wrong with tyler in that first
inning the fastball 92-93 didn't look
like himself at all well it turned out
that it was a migraine issue and now
xander bogarts who has a six-game hit
streak going
ground ball right side gloved by loud
throw to first is going to be in time
that will move verdugo over to third
that was a nice play by lau bogarts is
trying to take advantage of that open
right side jd is all for his last 17
down to 211.
and the breaking ball gets him swinging
at a miss quick work there
of jd martinez
against devaldi who is two and two of
the 498 era making his first start since
august 20th yeah vivaldi he's been bad
he's back it's like it came out of
nowhere that cap strain but he's only
going to go a couple innings we'll see
what he's got tonight and austin meadows
here to start it off
there's a high fly ball back into right
near the corner and that baby is going
to go
home run up into the seats the reigns
take an early lead on that 3-2 pitch
meadows unloads
dwayne that's the real estate home run
all about location down and in
right there that's that perfect uppercut
swing he throws it right into it turn on
for g mon choi who's at 2 23 with three
homers
he sends one toward the left field
corner munoz will go to the wall and
leap and that's going to be out of his
reach it's a double for g-man joy
wendell hit by a pitch
ivaldi trying to pitch out of it
and swung on and missed he struck him
out to strand two one nothing tampa bay
[Applause]
tampa bay up one nothing on a home run
and this one stung a diving stab there
by chavis he wins the foot race to set
low down really fine play by michael
there that that ball should have been a
double i mean that's a bullet right down
the first base line nathan ivaldi
there have been 31 stolen base attempts
off of him in
953 innings
i mean he does a great job of
controlling the running game for a
righty
now the runner goes and the swing of the
bench throw down
and they're gonna get margot trying to
get in head first and somehow get around
the tag that's why you don't that's why
you don't go
davis against glass now right on right
hitting 228 with a couple of home runs
he launches that one he looked like he
got it racing back margot at the wall it
is gone a home run chavis with number
three he is off to a rather good start
tonight i'll tell you what great
defensive play comes to bat first up
what new and goes bridge on a fastball
that he usually can't handle
senator bogart's deleted off in the top
of the fourth
fastball he walked him and his first
free pass tonight lucky coming into the
game hitting in the upper 320s
just in a stolen base for bogarts red
sex feeling like they can run on glass
now rbi chance here for plawecki
we've got ourselves a leaner chip down
he goes again look at this so two stolen
bases there for xander bogarts
and he's gonna rocket that one to center
down for a base hit here comes the run
xander bogart's in the score and the red
sox take a two to one lead glasnow has
no nobody to blame but himself on this
the rays have two on one out for nate
lowe
that's a line drive off the bat of nate
lowe into right
they will send choi to the plate and the
throws going to be up the line a bit so
the rays get their second round to tie
it joy sliding across the bag and a
little slow in getting up and uh he's
going to require some attention here he
was as he was going down you could see
it written all over his face that
something had gone wrong and he reached
back that's the second time he reaches
towards the back of that left leg that
hamstring and here's manuel margot with
rudders at the corner
and toward the gap into left center
field off the bat of margot that's gonna
go all the way to the wall adamus has
scored lowe's on his way to the plate
the throw will not be in time on a
double for margot and the rays take a
4-2 lead
we'll issue tyler glass now take a look
at that hand where you can see
the bleeding coming from that finger and
uh blood on the pant leg out there
before the game and the top of that
thumb and you could see the the
reflection of whatever that is obviously
trying to dry it right there one on one
off for verdugo
there's a popper left side
that will be caught by wendell and
they're going to double up chavis who
forgot how many outs there were
he headed for third and the reigns will
double up chavis off second and they get
him right there so here's arroyo he's
lined up hard to center he's also flied
to the center fielder
not running and that one is smoked hits
that one down the line watch it go and
it is gone first home run for christian
arroyo as he blasts a two-run shot he
has tied the ball game
brandon has ground to the first slide to
center and then he grounded at the
second base his last time
there's a high fly ball back into deep
right that's got a lot of carry and that
baby is out of here
home run for brandon lau
and the rays retake the lead it's 5-4
so the red sox are down to their final
out and munoz is due
that's a bullet down the line that one
hooked into the corner on a bounce it
will leave the ballpark so that's going
to be a double so the tying run is at
second with two men down and michael
chavis is due he's homered he's walked
a little tap toward third
wendell gloves and throws and the rays
win it chavis out third to first
ray's
win their 30th game of the year it's a
5-4 final